Yeah, I have started the recording,
so that please unmute yourself.
Yeah, thank you. Thank you, Ramesh.
We're going to start it. So Irina,
words to you.
to you.
Yeah,
I just wanted to show you like how this
PIM looks in read only,
but now I see that again it is not
available for me,
so unfortunately I cannot show you.
But in general we know that PIM is a
system where like legacy.
Product is stored.
We know that there we can even search
products,
but unfortunately for now we do not have
the information how the attributes of
like what means each attribute of the
product.
In order to analyze it,
but we know that we we will need to
understand how this current PIM structure
can be like mapped to our current
structure in the Picasso.
And also like we will need to understand
like how because currently we know that
different teams like create products in
different ways.
So we will need also to work.
Like to understand how we will work with
some historical data.
Basically like it's like general
description. Maybe Kristina,
you can add something more here.
Oh, Kristina, we cannot hear you.
We see that you are unmuted, but no audio.
Can you hear me now? OK, OK.
I I lost the last sentence from Ira. Ira.
Oh yes, we can.
Yeah, mm-hmm.
Can you please repeat?
Yeah,
I've described that like what is the
general purpose of working on the team
that we need to understand its structure
and how it can be mapped to Picasso.
Also we need to understand how.
Like how historical data should be
managed because like different teams
create products in different ways.
So this like 2 main topics for the PIM
integration and by the way I see is that
PIM is.
Available for me,
so I can just in general show you.
That for now like how how it looks.
Once you're navigating to the theme it
looks like this and filtering products
can be done on this advanced search
functionality.
Functionality and one we selecting
attribute so that we will be able to
search through different attributes and
including them.
Let's say let's use something like
product brand.
So we see that this like this attribute
will be included in search.
Yeah but but unfortunately we currently
do not understand what means each
attribute because as you can see that
once I'm starting typing that there is a
lot of different attributes so.
We need like some additional description
to know which attribute corresponds to
which characteristic of the product in
details. Yeah,
and I asked you first and maybe you can
provide even more like something more
details on the PIM integration in general.
Yeah, have you shown the APIs?
So because here actually we would have
Yes.
two parts. Yeah,
first one is actually the historical
records.
Picasso and specifically we would be
interested like as a first step in legacy
products now,
but later we would need also to
synchronize.
Existing Picasso products with the
products from PIN and then later on
update this information through APIs.
So PIM exposes APIs.
You can find them on APG portal.
So we would consume those APIs in order
to get information regarding the.
Attribute like you got the changes of
product attributes in PIM and update them
accordingly in Picasso.
What is important for us here to manage
is is their state of the product as we
believe that.
Like products in PIM should have
up-to-date statuses,
whether this is like product that is
actively developed or this is a product
that is.
In end of commercialization status or end
of support or end of life, whatever, yeah,
and this is what we would need to regular
regularly update in Picasso.
There also could be some other attributes
that we would need to consume.
From team and update in Picasso,
but this is not yet identified,
so for us it would be like APIs
consumption.
And they have lots of them,
so we can use whatever we want.
Mm.
Uh,
could you please add the documentation
also for this?
Uh APIs, the EPG APIs.
Mhm.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Give me a second. Uh.
Mm-hmm.
Sound it in the top.
Mm-hmm. Thank you.
You know,
is it possible to get access of this tool
just to check or? Mm-hmm.
Yes, it's possible.
Currently like in general what was
discussed with us that this tool will be
available only only in read only mode.
Mhm.
Like there's no possibility to to get to
some, let's say Q&AQA environment.
So etcetera.
So only read only and you need to pass a
self learning materials and like to go
through self learning materials and pass
quiz and after that automatically the Z
axis will be assigned to you. So like.
My.
In my case like some person send me a
good information.
We are teams that are currently the PM is
available for you.
Unfortunately there were some issues that
even this like still it wasn't available
Yeah.
for me,
but after they have done something on
their site it is available for me.
As in this mode as as you can see on the
screen,
I will share with you a link to this
materials to to pass the quiz.
Mm-hmm. Thank you.
And there are different types of PIM,
right?
Like PIM core and so which one are we
using?
Mm.
Yeah, and this, this,
this is probably an open question as of
Mhm.
now. Yeah,
what what's to what exactly to use and
how to map.
This is what we are working on.
Kristina,
do you have the access to this Limke
Developer API?
Mm yeah.
Mm.
Yeah.
But you should check it not in here.
You need to be logged like from your
Yeah.
On.
computer.
Mhm, mhm.
Not in the video.
Yeah,
it seems that like we don't have this
There you go.
like our video by twisted to access this
portal.
Mhm.
Hmm.
Interesting because in to PM I'm
accessing we are VDI. Hmm. OK.
Alright,
it's because when you have created a
request, it was added for this.
Oh, for this computer.
But APT documentation it's open for our
says I believe link to the.
VPN account that we are using.
Oh, OK.
And in Vijay we have different VPN.
Mm-hmm.
No, it's it's it's a stop.
Can you just type pin in the search bar?
Type Mhm.
Yeah, there are 10 APIs,
different APIs for PIM AIM contribution
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
document file incremental.
I think uh in product right? Uh.
A PIM Product Expert or a PIM search
might be as well.
No.
Search is also there,
but search has only one uh endpoint.
To get product related data. Mm-hmm.
Oh yeah,
product has multiple endpoints and files
and incrementals.
These are different APIs for based on
let's say a particular product I guess
from what these request and response seem
to be.
Mhm.
OK,
so can we now split this integration in
smaller pieces or you guys need some time
to go through the those like the
developer API or to have the connection
to PIM before or we can just draft some
ideas?
That's how to split it.
What we know right now that we for sure
will be using APG,
so the identification is clear, right?
That's understood.
And first we will use API for the
Mhm, yeah.
integration and it will be on the
outbound integration.
So we will only get the data,
read the data.
We are not planning to post something
from our site.
Right. Um.
But we don't know the exact set of the
calls and how the data corresponds and
like which API exactly we'll be using.
So on this one I believe that some
analysis needs to be done.
1.
OK, so to use those connections,
what we need to build from our side like
It's.
Mhm.
the UI then?
Hmm.
You are not clear if you need.
I don't know some develop.
Kristina, how we plan to have it?
Would it be like if some new product
available in PIM,
we are loading it on our site or it will
be look for the product when it is
registered?
And.
OK.
Believe that we would need like once the
product is created,
it's being created in Picasso and it
would be search from the products from
PIM. At the same time guys,
Please remember that in PIM we have the
products that are.
Available that are already sold.
So actually the offers while in Picasso
we could have bricks,
platforms that are not sold like as a
standalone product on the market,
so they don't have.
Commercial number.
This is the first point to remember.
The second point is that we could
register in Picasso, for example,
some products that are not yet
commercialized, for example,
the completely new one.
Yeah,
that are like in the development process
yet.
So that's why such products would not be
available in PIN yet,
like once they are released to the market,
once they got their commercial reference
number.
Then this product would appear in PIM and
we would need just to map. Yeah,
their records and yeah,
the third use case is so like, yeah,
the search.
For the existing product and right now we
do not distinguish, for example,
internal applications and other products,
so we don't have such.
Attribute right now in product details
top, yeah,
but still we have such records in Picasso
as of now.
So now the internal applications of
Schneider Electric and they would never.
Ever have these PIN corresponding PIN
record? Yeah,
so they could exist without PIN.
So answering the question, yeah,
so we can either search for corresponding
product in PIM.
We could for example create Picasso
Mhm.
product without PIM connection.
Yeah,
and later connect our product in Picasso
with PIM product. Yeah,
once it is added there and we could have
Mhm.
cases where the product in Picasso
doesn't have corresponding record in PIM
at all.
And As for the search,
it's like during the registration of the
product or like when like kind of a daily
update,
we get the information that there are
some products registered in BIM and we
create them by default in Picasa and just
waiting for the users.
No, we don't. Yeah, no, no.
We don't need to create like,
Turn like.
Mhm.
I'm not saying dummy records. Yeah,
but records just, just, just,
Mm-hmm. Like draft products. Mm-hmm.
just as draft. No, we don't need.
It's just like in case, yeah,
we need to have them in Picasso.
Mhm.
OK.
So like it's anyway starts with the user
registering the product.
We are we are not doing it instead of
them. Mm-hmm.
Mhm.
OK,
but we will show some sort of the linkage
right here with PIM.
So we will have update for this like
search of the UI and update of the
product details like we'll show somehow
the connection with PIM if it is.
Available.
Mm-hmm.
I think that no BIM records is kind of
what we have right now.
I don't know if you need to cover it
exactly. So to kind of link.
Mm-hmm.
So we need just the ability to push it to
So you have registered something and you
are looking if it is available and add
PIM, right? Uh, to sort.
Mhm.
this link.
Between those two objects like for
example by some unique ID that we have in.
Product to lean.
Um.
Mhm.
OK,
so we need first UI and the UI for search
UI for like link linking.
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
I like the error.
Also,
once we like search and we'll have
product details,
so are we going to allow users to update
any of those details or it will be like
it only?
Like before saving in Picasso.
Will we import some port details from PIM?
I have missed this part.
Kristina, maybe I have missed this part.
I understood that we are like using it
only for linkage,
but are we going to like to search for
some details that are specified for the
product in BIM and also transfer it to
Picasa?
Uh, so um.
What we would need like once we have,
yeah, the link between Picasso and Beam,
Mhm.
then yeah,
if for example we have some updates of
attributes and probably we would monitor
just like a few maybe.
Two or like up to five attributes of this
product. Yeah,
we would need to update them in because.
Like for example,
what I can think about is the state of
the product. Yeah, if it is changed,
for example,
it was active and now it is like end of
support. Yeah,
then we need to get this information from
team like once.
Mhm.
The update is so.
Done. They are.
Mm-hmm. OK.
So we we will,
we will have some some fields which will
be taken only from PIM.
If we have this linkage added and that
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, yeah, correct.
needs to be refreshed, right?
And also I believe that like mapping
between our values and the data in BIM
will be covered in back office, right?
So for example,
if they have the instead of end of life
state something like duplicated,
we will need to map it somehow to our end
of life state.
Mm-hmm. Yeah, right.
They might have different text.
Yeah,
the and it will be something that will be
You know.
completed by the because that means not
that for each product,
but for the whole integration. So I think.
Will we have ability to push from Picasso
products to PIM or only link?
We have read only access. Irina mentioned,
right? Mm-hmm.
Mm-hmm.
OK, so we can only grab the data.
Mhm.
All right.
But they do have a page right Irina for
like a two week communication.
I'm not sure like I believe that we can
study this document that was shared
because we didn't have connection with
any of the PIN representatives so far.
Yeah, after this call, let me check once.
So Iryna, who is the point of?
And what what for do you need to a
connection like two way connections?
No, no,
I'm just checking like since Urad was
asking right so.
Yeah, just wanted to check.
Maybe you have some ideas. Mm-hmm.
No, no,
this is this totally depends on the
requirements, right?
So currently it's not requirement.
OK.
So you know who is the point of contact?
Like in case we need credentials to test
the APIs.
I'm not sure because we were talking with
Hussain and Hiba regarding PIM integrate
PIM integration and after that a person
with a name. Let me check.
Mhm.
Um.
He is Rahul Sharma who shared with me
updates regarding my access.
Um.
Mhm.
Alright,
any other thoughts what we might missed?
All right, so maybe Irina,
you can share with Ramesh what you
already have in terms of drafts,
just the URLs. Ramesh,
you will try to request the access to PIM,
pass the training and then we will
Mhm.
regroup on this.
Once you will have a little bit more
details and we we will try to put the
high level estimates for each topic what
we have at risk or just update what
defined here based on your knowledge.
Could you please share these two
screenshots,
Right.
PIM and the legacy product one also?
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, sure. Yeah, yeah, I will.
I will put it in the chat.
Hello.
So I shared 2 links in the chat and the
second one is actually with this read
only materials.
In the section business concept you will
see some mandatory presentations and
mandatory and optional and once you will
scroll a little bit lower you.
Will find a link to the quiz.
Mm-hmm. Thank you.
All right, so let me check. Yes,
I can put the image one and image 2.
OK. So any questions, any comments?
No, nothing from my side.
OK. So, yeah,
then let's close the call and then
regroup later,
maybe this later this week or next week,
right. Thank you. Thank you, everyone.
Yep. Thank you. Thank you so much.
Have a good day.
Bye, bye.
Mhm. Thank you.